o lado diz pessoal de quem fala é o dark
sejam muito bem vindos já mais de um
vídeo e mostrados aqui minha reação ao
trailer do fight night at freddy's 4 eu
já tinha feito um vídeo deste ano para o
trailer do filme médio andrés 3 que
vocês é duraram o vídeo não sei porquê
mas vocês gostam de ver a boca com
trailer bom eu ainda não vi o trailer
obviamente não era estúpido fazer este
vídeo mandar uma bola no twitter é
melhor ter cinco ex suplente pois eu
avisei aqui no twitter que fazer este
vídeo por contém vocês formaram o
twitter para eu fazer este vídeo reação
ao trailer de farmácia fredes 4 eu não
sabia que os 4 a 1 também já tem mandado
o trailer do canal de erro mas enfim o
tema já está aí eu vou agora é assistir
o trailer e vamos lá ver o que é que vai
ser o fanatismo 34 eu espero que este
jogo seja muito melhor com familiares de
freddy 3 porque não cheguei sem tanta
piada o jogo foi de 31 e os dois estavam
bem melhores e eu acho mas vamos lá
então assistir o trailer não dá conta
nisso ok
acho que paguei não ficou sozinho no
imóvel até agora vai 321 pra lá meu deus
staton ao sistema é um time que quer e
vamos honrar tudo ok eu disse o que
pensa e faz virar algo assim chama casa
estava focada em casa
o jogo vai passar dentro de uma casa
não digo que esta [ __ ] vai ser dentro
de uma casa mesmo
uol por cima de alguém por cima de
alguém
o caso não está uma casa foi suas portas
e estrangulada por seu não pode não pode
não viu um armário um fox tudo comida
toma cuidado ou mais em foco não está
lendo isto vai ficar lindo
companheiros
fight night at freddy's 4 rock
isto vai estar simplesmente brutal eo
nem sequer perceber o que é que eu estou
te ver estar outra vez forçou e alguma
coisa no corredor
eu não sei se é o boni eu foquei boni
estão os prep um boneco tipo de boneco
mesmo boneco tem um blues só assim eu
acho eu já tô um pouco desatualizado das
coisas acerca do fluminense fred por
isso vocês souberem que tipo de animal
entrou em acção este homem tem embaixo
só não quer saber tudo acerca deste
fanatismo freddie 4 tenho certeza que
vocês sabem mais do que eu né estão fox
eo gastar tudo comigo no fucinho mesmo
isto é muito isto é muito bizarro meu
que é esperada para trás mesmo que o
[ __ ] é extra o que é isto em cima da
cama não façam em cima da cama for
saindo do armário e que não espera
esperar que ambos querem baixar o volume
ok o meu deus o meu deus quer que o que
é isto
o seu boné e foi embora eu tá muito
creep está muito foi veja os dentes
deu-me eu não tenho um tipo dentadura
mantê lo então é isso só vamos ficar
porque construir espero que vocês tenham
estado sempre foi um vídeo muito pequeno
mas pronto é só mesmo a minha reação ao
trailer do fat freddy's 4 estou super
ansioso para jogar este jogo depois de
ver isto eu não sei se os quatro
capitães já disse mais coisas acerca do
jogo mas se usada em estigma e nos
comentários que sofre receber as coisas
novas que conseguiram família até 34
micronics enfim vocês souberem de alguma
e nos comentários mas é isso pessoal com
uma faca favorito fique bem e até a
próxima